Oh baby oh yeah oh yeah scrub away I  love cleaning brings me so much joy it  sounds terrible  cleaning is my actual nightmare Jess and  I are gonna be cleaning this whole  kitchen  did you see how happy she was about that  you're sick clean I'll be using this I  will be using this I'm happy to land  [Music]  come on this is a stubborn one you are  having some trouble over there it seems  [Music]  clean that is clean as a baby's bottom  got clean Oh your long arms have nothing  on me  not even scrubbing Oh baby look at this  grime this is where the magic happens  [Music]  yeah okay  relax it was a draw you didn't win it  like one point where I thought you were  just meditating this is your peaceful  place it's actually weird